on the streets of this quiet town in the
suburbs of paris
the aftermath of a horrific act of
terror
and this is the victim named as samuel
patty a teacher
in his 40s brutally murdered on this
street
his killer shot dead by the police
it's understood the murderer was
incensed because the teacher had started
a debate with his pupils about
caricatures of the prophet muhammad
my son who is muslim who sat in this
class he is disgusted
he's very disappointed he told me this
was a teacher he liked
a very nice very pleasant teacher not
islamophobic
or whatever
well he's disturbed in any case i'm not
putting him back to school
it's over this is the end
he
was attacked in a cowardly way and the
victim of an islamist terrorist attack
just last month two people were wounded
in a knife attack in paris near the
former
offices of the satirical magazine
charlie hebdo
[Music]
five years ago 12 people were killed
when the magazine was attacked by gunmen
part of a series of attacks in france
that took many lives
the trial of alleged accomplices is
going on now
in paris
the murderer is believed to have been an
18 year old
it's reported he posted images of the
attack on social media
before he was shot by police at the
scene adam parsons sky news
confluence and honoring